le royaume uni va consacrer une
enveloppe de 768 millions d'euros au
renforcement de ses frontières en vue du
bric site
le but se préparait à la fin de la
période de transition du mexique prévue
au 1er janvier 2021
cet investissement il inclut des
dépenses d'infrastructures elle et le
personnel comme le recrutement d'environ
500 nouveaux agents de la police aux
frontières dans une tribune publiée dans
le sunday telegraph le ministre d'état
michael gove assuré qu'il s'agit de
faire de cette frontière la plus
efficace du monde d'ici à 2025 et pour
en parler on va retrouver paul thompson
10 président du parti conservateur
britannique à paris bonjour à vous merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france d'abord un comment un commentaire
sur cette enveloppe
le brics ici coûte cher au royaume uni
je pense que on savait qu'il fallait des
dépenses supplémentaires pour gérer une
situation nouvelle
donc je ne pense pas que s'il s'agit de
dépenses excessives ou inconsidérées
dans comme il faut mais aurélie les
dépenses par rapport aux enjeux ici les
orgies sont très importants en matière
de sécurité
parce qu'il y en a je sécurité revêt
aussi un enjeu économique et et encore
donc ça coûte quelque chose ce n'est pas
trop chappard oppose aux enjeux 768
millions d'euros a pour cette enveloppe
alors quels sont les projets
britanniques autour de ce dispositif
frontalier
eh bien il a eu donc une annonce
officielle hier qui a été repris je
pense par le sunday telegraph
il s'agit comme vous avez dit engagé à
du personnel pour apporter les assurés
de sécurité des frontières mais il y à
aussi à et en termes de poids icône en
termes du coup ça représente plusieurs
fois le cours sont donc environ du
personnel pour améliorer les systèmes
digitaux entre autres pour permettre un
fonctionnement plus
plus plus fluide avec un minimum de
friction à la frontière et quand je dis
à la frontière en fait il y aura
également des âmes des centres loin des
frontières
après ça ne va pas sur la côte pour
permettre aux entreprises qui exportent
qui importe de de faire en sorte que le
processus se déroule au mieux donc il ya
aussi des investis sur investissement
pendant dans une infrastructure digit
est mais également physique
ensuite il y a eu une campagne
d'information pour le public en général
mais également paul et les entreprises
qui devront faire face à une nouvelle
donne ce n'est pas l'idée le concept
n'est pas nouveau bien entendu mais
maintenant on en arrive vraiment à la
mise en oeuvre de la chose dès le 1er
janvier
donc là aussi il y a à gogo dance on a à
nous dire a mentionné deux choses une
campagne d'information à destinés aux
entreprises et aux particuliers et plus
spécifiquement un guide qui décrira
exactement comment voir fonctionner les
frontières ne doute est d'avoir à un
système qui permet le passage des biens
avec un minimum de friction est ce que
les en termes d'infrastructures les
ports et autres infrastructures vont
seront prêtes avant la fin justement des
négociations avec bruxelles dans cette
période de transition
il faudra bien qu il que tu sois prêt
pour la la fin de l'année je ne peux pas
vous dire
enfin ce que je vais vous dire c'est que
le gouvernement britannique ne va pas
dévier de son chemin qui consiste à
sortir vraiment la fin de cette année et
je pense que cette annonce a en fait
deux objectifs un objectif à l'intérieur
ça veut dire qu'ils visent les
britanniques eux mêmes leur entreprise
leur particulier à et l'organisation des
services publics concernés
l'autre dimension est externe et il
s'agit d'un message en direction de
michel barnier que vous voit sur l'écran
et et les l'union européen des
dorénavant du 27 et le message c'est que
nous nous partons à la fin de l'année
michael gough dans son annonce diarra
repris des formules maintes fois utilisé
on reprend le contrôle de nos frontières
on va se mettre en est sûre de profiter
de nouvelles opportunités parce qu'on
sera plus agile en tant que pays
autonome en nouant de nouvelles
relations avec des pays tiers les états
unis l'australie la chine le japon s'est
tracée pour développer le commerce
international et donc à ce message en
direction de l'europe et l'union
européenne à vise à accroître la
pression pour que ces négociations
n'avancent pas ce que le royaume uni a
intérêt comme d'une européenne à ce que
on arrive à un accord avant avant la fin
de l'année pour que la période de
transition soit suivie à deux bases
nouvellement convenu mais il s'agit de
dire très clairement que ne loi unis pas
de toute façon à accor ou ou pas éteint
message clé qui est encore une fois
réitérés par de nous dire merci beaucoup
à vous en parle comme ça ne rappelle que
vous êtes vice-président du parti
conservateur britannique apparition